The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right,
so let's get started.
OK, good afternoon.
Finally spring here,
so which means you want
to be out, not inside a room.
First, we're going to go
over the strategy aspect.
This will give us a chance to
reflect the whole content we
went through the whole term by
maybe using the idea of setting
up a strategy to try to connect
the different sessions that
kind of covered throughout.
And also we're going to
spend some time on the team
project final deliverable.
I know there's some questions.
You're going to-- you're meeting
with us if you haven't already
meet already.
And I want to
answer those so you
are prepared to work
on the final report.
And then on Wednesday, we're
going to hear firsthand
from EMC on how they think
about sustainability strategy,
the sustainability group.
So the direct order
[INAUDIBLE] the head people,
they're going to come here.
And you have a chance
to validate and maybe
get some of your
questions answered
on how a company actually makes
these happen in a little bit
larger scale.
STUDENT: If you guys
want to go online too,
EMC has one of the better
sustainability [INAUDIBLE]
reporting.
G on their website
and look around
at what kind of
information they're
disclosing so you can look
at that relative to what
your company [INAUDIBLE].
Because I would say
they're sort of the game
and also maybe some questions
to think about Katie
[? Sindel ?] who will
becoming on Wednesday.
PROFESSOR: Great, so that's
[INAUDIBLE] little bit
of the administrative aspect.
So this paper-- who
had read it before?
Before we assigned it?
So in the past-- in which
context did you read it?
STUDENT: It was for a
McKinsey thing I was
on like a while back-- 2007.
PROFESSOR: OK, how about you?
Where did you read it before?
STUDENT: Oh, sorry.
I thought [INAUDIBLE] class
PROFESSOR: Oh, OK.
This actually is
a very good paper.
[INAUDIBLE] this
is actually the one
I always go back to over time.
Because it has some fundamental
insights that I think
is worth revisiting.
This is, even though it's
not written for supply chain
necessarily-- it's not written
for environmental supply chain
either.
It's really more general CSR.
But I think some of the
key aspects of this paper
are, I think, critical
when you have to make
this happen in practice.
This is very much connected
to what we see and Alexis
and I have been
talking to people on,
especially the
pitfalls-- so how people
address environmental aspects
in their company and beyond.
So why don't we start by who
would like to kind of give me
a summary of the premise, the
basic premise, that Porter
puts forward in this article?
So we'll [INAUDIBLE]
STUDENT: Well, you've got to say
that just the CSR is not enough
and that people
are going to take
the CSR as like the
end-all and trying
to put it in these indexes
without really knowing
all of the true information.
So by doing that,
they're actually
kind of going away from
their true goal, which
is improvement in these areas.
So it's kind of looking at
what are different ways that
aside from this generally
accepted [INAUDIBLE] that we
can use to get
companies to focus more
on the social aspect,
social responsibility.
PROFESSOR: OK, that's one.
Would you like to add
something to that?
STUDENT: It advocates for
moving from corporate social
responsibility towards
corporate social integration
and also that sometimes
this companies
spread their resources too
thin [INAUDIBLE] NGO demands
or kind of external pressures
that aren't necessarily that
integral to their supply chain.
[INAUDIBLE] perhaps
have more of an impact
if they focus on one
area in particular.
PROFESSOR: Let me see if I can
get those three ideas here.
One is the, I guess focus
too much on the stakeholders.
We'll talk a little bit
more about that one.
They integrate to the
business I guess [INAUDIBLE]
what you were saying as well.
So [INAUDIBLE] the index traps
is one of the stakeholders.
And this is not a
trivial problem.
And let me just
relate back-- I'm
not sure I can tell the
full company name yet.
But soon we will.
So we were talking about
other major, major companies.
And we were asking
them, how do you
start your green
sustainability strategy?
They said, we did this.
We went to all the indexes
that were out there that
were ranking companies.
We looked exactly at why
they were ranking as well.
And then we started
addressing, they give us
like a guiding post we wanted
to achieve, want to be number
one in all those indexes.
And then we look at what was the
feedback they were providing us
and we work at it.
And we're doing very well.
They're ranked much better,
of course, than before.
But this is
specifically addressed
in this Porter article
specifically advises
against that.
So it advises against it
in multiple dimensions.
One dimension is, you
know, these indexes
are convoluted, right?
But there's a
fundamental, I guess,
problem is that this doesn't go
beyond what your company does.
It's what somebody
else cares about,
not what your
company cares about.
And the indexes, though they are
the most visible part, that's
not really is not going to be
there to stay, I think, yeah?
That's really the thing is it's
not that it's bad to use them.
It's just that if you think
that's the ultimate goal,
you will never be able to go the
momentum beyond the CSR head.
Whomever started
this project, great.
They're going to be
able to move this ahead.
But once this person leaves
or the company changes,
to this is going to be gone.
This could be five years.
This could be seven years.
That's unknown, but
that's, I think,
one of the ultimate problems.
So I want to list--
to tell that story.
But focus too much
on the stakeholder.
And so you had a third idea
but I forgot what it was.
You forgot?
STUDENT: I forget too.
PROFESSOR: OK, good.
That's good Anything
else that you
think were the key messages
from this articles that
are not those three?
STUDENT: I thought
the way he wrote down
four different types of CRS.
So there was the
license to operate,
the [INAUDIBLE] obligation,
sustainability, and [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I think
taht's pretty good too.
And the reason I
think it's pretty good
is because most of us, the first
time we think through this,
these are the four that come
to mind of why a company do it.
So one is a moral argument.
The other one was the
license to operate argument.
The other one that is maybe
the one that we even within MIT
we talk about more is the
sustainability argument.
And the third one
is the reputation.
Who remembers why those four
key claims are incomplete?
It's not that they're wrong.
It's that they were incomplete
to capture the true motivation
and meaning to drive and move
change in an organization
towards CSR or sustainability.
So let's talk about
the moral argument.
What was the main
problem of using
a moral view of the world to
say, this is what we should do?
This is the good
thing for us to do.
This is why our
business you do it.
STUDENT: It wasn't
very easily measurable.
PROFESSOR: Number one is
measurement, which is always
going to be a challenge, right?
So, measurement.
So what was the problem
with the moral--
what was the problem with
the measurement aspect?
Not easily measurable,
that's one thing.
But what does he mean by that?
STUDENT: I think there
are some things that
are kind of like a [INAUDIBLE]
a great area [INAUDIBLE] you
do one thing, but you kind of
destroy value in another area.
And how do you actually
get that to mesh?
PROFESSOR: Yes,
so the measurement
is that we all as
individuals, we probably
have our own moral values.
And when we decide, should I
take that extra piece of coke--
I paid for one drink,
I want to top it off.
You put, like, a little
bit more than you paid for.
You do, like, a moral
analysis, right?
And you do it internally
in the [INAUDIBLE], right?
You say, well, you know,
last time I had less.
So maybe on average,
I'm consuming
the right amount of soda.
And I'm OK with going
back to the line
and getting soda even
though I paid for one drink.
It's like a moral choice, hm?
And you do it at the
individual level.
It's easy maybe to do those
tradeoffs because they're not
quantifiable.
But if you go like
a big company--
they use the example
of Google-- you
have two different
moral choices, right?
There's one-- openness.
You want freedom.
But on the hand, you
also want to give access
to people to technology.
So how do you balance those two?
And when you cannot
measure things,
it all becomes a choice that
is of leadership or some sort.
And you cannot translate
that into business over time.
That's one.
The other thing is
the moral compass
changes-- changes from
one place to the other,
from one context to the other.
How can a company
be run that way?
It's not that morality is not
part of the business decisions,
but rather making that the
main driving force for CSR
does not allow you to
do trade offs property.
That's kind of what his main
argument was-- a measurement
aspect.
Lack of measurement is
reality on moral decisions.
But you cannot make
the trade offs.
And businesses are
all about trade offs.
That was one of his main
I'd say counter arguments.
So that's morality.
License to operate--
STUDENT: He said that
they don't take--
so as you're trying to look good
in the eyes of the community
you operate in, you are
[INAUDIBLE] to their requests
by you're not taking it
into account how you operate
and what your competitive
advantages are.
PROFESSOR: Yes,
there's a dichotomy
between your capabilities
and what these community
wants, right?
So that's not
taken into account.
Also, this goes back--
he talks in there
about different
context as well, right?
The context [INAUDIBLE].
Reputation-- this is
the interesting one.
Because actually, I
spent a lot of time
on trying to look
for this information.
What was the main argument
against the reputation
kind of bad approach
for justifying CRS?
Someone remembers?
STUDENT: A lot of
times, it can just--
PROFESSOR: Very quickly.
STUDENT: --just a
marketing campaign
instead of like a true
measure of what they're doing.
Like, so they're just--
PROFESSOR: There's
something more fundamental.
It's true, it's a
bit of marketing.
But it's not proven.
See, there's not
even-- we are not
able to find real evidence
that this actually works,
that this branding creates
business value, which
is very surprising.
But it's surprising because
in the companies that
are willing to do
it very well, it's
hard to differentiate how much
is brand, how much is business.
How do you make that argument?
And I think we tried several
times, [? Alexis, ?] to find
some good studies that
show that being greener
gives you better return over
investment or business value.
But actually, most of the
studies have it reverse.
They say, well, companies
that are doing great,
they tend to be greener,
right, or more sustainable.
But you can never find
the other argument.
So doesn't mean that
there's no value in it.
It's just hard to
distinguish that value
from the normal operation
of the business.
So even if you try
to go that path,
you will not ever get a good
sense of how good value they
will give you, which
goes back to why
will you even choose to do it?
When the times get tough
and you have to cut budgets,
how can justify doing this?
I mean, he always
thinks on how businesses
should do this later.
So a little bit of
the value of marketing
is unclear value of brand.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
do it the opposite way
that if you got attacked
like in the case of Nestle
and-- Nestle and Kit
Kat situation when
there was the Greenpeace
attacks and we
wanted to see the stop dip.
And it maybe went down
a few cents for one day
and evened out.
So unfortunately, even
the reverse is not true.
PROFESSOR: The only example
we found which actually
is the scary example, the
only one was Nike, probably,
back in the labor market.
That's the only example
that has been documented
that is closer correlated
between the attacks
that they had on labor and
the actual stock value.
But there were other factors
going on in that time.
But that was enough to scare
people across the world, which
is good.
I'm not saying this
is a bad thing,
but he argues that
it's not enough.
And then we go to
sustainability.
That-- what's the
argument he uses
for sustainability not
being a good driving force?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] There's
not a lot of basis for it
and it can also lead to
misunderstanding the long term
cost for short term gains.
PROFESSOR: So it's vague.
So the definition is great,
but what is the long term?
I mean, how long
is the long term?
How am I trading
off the long term?
Is this 10 years?
Is this 100 years?
Is this 50 years?
But I have to make decisions
now and evaluate it now.
And if I always have to
make these trade offs
long term and short
term, the natural path
is going to be
postponed the long term.
And you could just postpone
it, postpone it, postpone it.
And it's hard to make
it, on a regular basis,
a decision of the short
term because it's so vague.
Not know that it's
the wrong framework,
but it's too undefined.
I think those more or less were
the four arguments, roughly
speaking, that were outlining
in the wrong reasons
to do stability.
However, you talk to people,
these are easier to explain.
Look at it any CEO's pitch.
All of them, if someone
is in operations,
they talk about this license to
operate-- like risk [INAUDIBLE]
a little bit of risk.
Risk management is very
easy to understand.
If I don't do the
right thing, they're
going to kick me out of
China or out of Brazil.
That's a very, very
natural way to do it.
This also touches people.
That's a good way to get
a rallying cry for change.
This, of course, is just
as the overall-- I guess
is the overall trend that you
in general by NGOs and media
and actually ourselves
here in academia.
And reputation is
another risk argument.
And it's very well understood.
You can bring it
into your company.
But all of those
four, he basically
says those should not
be the right ones.
OK, so that's kind of the
summary of the bad things that
were happening.
So he proposes a
specific framework
to try to think about this.
So who would like to kind of
give the idea of framework
he proposes?
[INAUDIBLE] remembers?
Doesn't this table?
I think the table is in page 18.
It says how to
prioritize social issues.
And he talks about
two types of CSR.
Well, it's actually the other
one-- it's page nine, probably,
is a little bit better.
Page nine, he talks about
these generic social impacts,
value chain social impacts,
and social dimensions
of competitive context.
As you can, I always say Porter
is really good with words.
Social dimensions of competitive
context-- pretty good.
But those three
once basically are
the way he proposes you
should think about this.
So let me see-- who ventures
to try to make sense
of these three dimensions?
Some one?
Guesses?
Sorry, [? Gosa? ?] We have
someone [INAUDIBLE] [? Gosa? ?]
Two people?
No one is venturing
yes, someone venture.
Go ahead.
Save the day.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] answer.
PROFESSOR: The
answer is no answer?
[INAUDIBLE] So what he
basically-- yeah, go ahead.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] say that
there are [INAUDIBLE] should
be more integrated.
So a typical
response [INAUDIBLE]
to be more responsible and
to be [INAUDIBLE] in a way
[INAUDIBLE] dimension
and something that
goes beyond just the response
to the sentiment of society
[INAUDIBLE] to bring [INAUDIBLE]
further in a [INAUDIBLE] way
to operate [INAUDIBLE]
responsibility [INAUDIBLE].
And I will give an example.
Like, for example, there's a
positive [INAUDIBLE] for me.
It means that they
have this strategy
of not only, for example,
being a zero carbon [INAUDIBLE]
but they want to go
beyond it and [INAUDIBLE]
than they virtually consume
in their [INAUDIBLE] homes
and so have a net positive
impact in the end.
So for me,
[INAUDIBLE] like this.
PROFESSOR: So there
we have-- on one end,
we have the good
citizenship, I guess.
But what does he
really mean here?
Is it-- could you
say that again?
Maybe I missed.
What is the position
for a company
in the good citizenship--
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It's a
little bit of saying,
do nothing, but do
nothing responsibly.
So basically, do nothing.
You know, just take
a look at stuff.
Just do the basics.
Just stay there.
Stay there.
Definitely have
a code of conduct
on how to do labor practices.
But you don't have to
make these something very
important in your company.
You just have to make
sure people understand
what expectations are,
have the minimal compliance
in some sense, and just
do the right thing.
It's like what we do every day.
Comply with the laws.
Maybe you do not-- you're
not looking actively
to see how these
laws are changing.
You just do them.
That's a bit on the left side.
Why is this hard
for companies to do?
STUDENT: Sorry.
PROFESSOR: Yes?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
I was saying,
being like a good
citizen means, like,
trying to avoid adverse
effects from the business.
PROFESSOR: So just
avoidance-- avoidance
of effects on the business.
So just make sure you
don't end up in jail, eh?
Which is-- this doesn't do
for a good marketing campaign.
So we're going to avoid to
be in jail on labor issues.
We're going to avoid to be
in jail on carbon footprint.
I mean, that's why companies
don't talk about this that way.
Because you have to.
It's not that sexy.
So that's on one spectrum.
So this is a little
bit of say no.
Say no thanks.
So say no, I'm not going to
try to solve this problem.
I am aware of it.
I recognize it and
I'm going to try
to do what the basic
[INAUDIBLE] but I'm really
not going to spend resources
or time trying to do this, hm?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] that is
just avoiding the [INAUDIBLE]
while doing [INAUDIBLE].
Because [INAUDIBLE]
it's also [INAUDIBLE]
to being to address
consequences of [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so he talks
about it in a little bit
of the next stage.
He says there's
generic social impacts.
And then he has these
value chain social impacts.
So there'll be some
of those that will
be closer to your business.
So there's a few
of them that may
be not as distant as others.
But the ones that are a bit
closer, then definitely I
want to mitigate.
So in a little bit,
then, they move
to say, no thanks,
to mitigate risk.
But you're right.
In some sense, you want to list
them down and have some sort
of conscious decision.
And I think this
is-- anyone that
has studied strategy
knows that strategy is not
what you decide to do.
It's what most of
the time you make
sure you are not going to do.
I'm not going to try to--
it's hard sometimes to say,
I'm not going to
do this or that.
But someone, when you have
a good strategy your head,
you know-- this issue?
I know it's important, but I'm
not going to try to tackle it.
That's a little bit of what
the [INAUDIBLE] is trying
to put forward here is
that you, even though it's
hard to say no to one of these
issues, you have to say no.
Because you cannot
solve them all.
That's the one end.
And then on the other
end, we have the more--
we call strategic CSR.
This is what he
calls responsiveness,
I guess responsive CSR.
That is on the
framework of try to say
no to try to mitigate risk.
And on the other hand, you
have the strategic CSR aspects
of it.
Those are the ones that
you have to say yes to.
You say yes to in
two different ways.
One is the-- I think you
were saying earlier--
is the one that tries to
create new competitiveness
dimensions as a company.
I think they use Whole
Foods as one example.
This is my competitiveness.
Like, my [INAUDIBLE]
organic food
and I'm engaged with consumers.
I'm engaged with
the community and I
do everything just
to position myself
as a completely different
retailer where people can find
certain goods, where
people can actually
not only get their products,
but help the community.
And they attract a
certain kind of market.
And everything sustainability
around Whole Foods
is really tied to not
only their values,
but it's how they see
themselves competing.
Most people-- Whole
Foods prides themselves
that whenever there's a Whole
Foods in a neighborhood,
the real estate values increase.
Because this is like a
source of change, hm?
And they compete that way.
And every green
environmental dimension
is tied to that competitiveness.
But they also very
much so charge more.
Now, most people cannot
afford Whole Foods.
So it's not the only value
proposition that a retailer can
have. [INAUDIBLE] other
that are different-- scales
and just other things we
will talk about later.
But that's the example
of a strategic CSR.
And there's another--
he actually talks
about another example there.
And we saw this-- we were
talking with Siemens.
And I think you can help me
here with some of the Siemens
vision.
So Siemens, they do all
kinds of electrical equipment
for big power plants.
So for them, green energy is
the business of the future.
So they decided,
we're going to sell
all kinds of hydro wind energy.
And they put lots of effort
into trying to sell this
to other companies.
But the only way you
can sell this outside
is if you use it inside.
If you don't have good energy
practices in your company,
you cannot sell the
product outside.
So for them, it became quickly
a transformation of the culture
and trying to do a much better
job with their own suppliers
in energy management.
Because that's the
only way you can
justify that future positioning
of selling wind energy
and selling the future energy
solutions for the world.
You have to sell new
products and then
you have to work on
your supply chain
to be as energy efficient as
the products yo want to sell.
So they kind of transformed
their CSR and their supply
chain environmental practices,
focusing on energy reduction
and energy savings, because
this was fully aligned
to how they wanted to compute.
GE is also mentioned,
[INAUDIBLE]
imagination projects.
You hear about GE.
Same thing-- they
see it as the future.
People are buying these
products so my company also
has to be very good at
mentioning energy use
and saving energy
throughout my manufacturing
plants and my suppliers and
my suppliers' suppliers.
I need to be consistent
because this helps
my positioning of my brand.
And also, these suppliers
are going to be my customers.
If I sell energy
solutions and my supplier
needs to improve their energy,
they'll buy my products.
So they had a bit of a
virtue circle, I guess.
Toyota is the same thing.
Toyota, they mentioned here
in the case in the article.
Now, there is-- the
other group they
call here is called
transform value chain
activities to benefit society
while reinforcing a strategy.
That's a mouthful.
What does it mean?
STUDENT: I think-- well, it
gives the example of Nestle.
And he's just talking
about fully integrating
whatever your CSR
priorities are into how
you do business every day.
And that's what Nestle does.
They work with small farmers.
And so their impact
is fully integrated
into their company strategy.
PROFESSOR: So it's just,
so what you do, do it well.
And do it well sustainably.
So Nestle is a great example.
UPS-- who's working with UPS
and FedEx in their-- so UPS,
another great example.
So UPS, they also have
what-- the business
of packaging on the distance
is a very thin margin business.
Every single decision you
make that saves-- especially
at the scale of Fedex or UPS
or any of these packaging
companies, any
gallon of fuel you
save in one route multiplied
by the number of routes
you run by every day multiplied
per year, it's millions and
millions of dollars of savings.
And if you do it well,
your business runs better.
And what they have
embraced sustainability
is to connect it to
that particular thing.
We are going to save
fuel to the nth degree
in every single operation we do.
And this connects with
what they do very well.
That is logistics
and transportation.
So that's kind of about another
example of look at what you do
and what you do
that matters to you.
You're going to do it as
sustainably or whatever
the dimension as possible.
You're going to
leverage what you're
good at to try to expand and
make it sustainable in some way
or another.
And transform that function
into a competitive advantage.
That's kind the
idea that he has.
There's a problem with
all of this, though.
We'll talk about
the problem later.
But that's the strategic CSR.
It's strategic because
you see a new market
coming or strategic because you
have core competence in the way
you run your business.
And because of that, you
should spend time there
and do it better.
I think that that's
the basics, the way
I like to see his article.
And if you ever go to
a company or-- this
is a good one to keep around.
[INAUDIBLE] to go back to it
and read it multiple times
over your lifetime.
So before you lose your
access to the MIT libraries,
have it print a copy.
Or you have to pay--
how much is it? $6.99?
Well, you'll have the
budgets in the future.
But let's look a little more
about what-- anything else
that I have not covered on the
basic messages of this article
that someone would like
to highlight that maybe he
mentions at the end?
No?
All right.
STUDENT: I just wanted
to make a comment.
PROFESSOR: Yeah
STUDENT: I'm taking a marketing
class, a branding class right
now.
And the main takeaway
I got from here that's
synonymous with what we're
learning in our branding class
is DNA.
What we see in a lot of
different case studies
we've read is that when a
company doesn't incorporate
the brand new message
and the attributes
of-- the key attributes of
the company into their DNA,
then they fall short
and they're less
competitive against other
people who do it well.
And so that's kind
of what I see.
He's actually saying
that if you're
going to position yourself
and integrate yourself
as this environmental
conscious company,
make sure you've intertwining
within the DNA of your company
and don't just do it to
address some hot issue that's
in the news at
this point in time
or that it sounds
favorable because it's
the flavor of the month.
Make sure that you integrate
it in everything that you do.
And then that will
have a huge benefit
to your company in the
short term and long term.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so
there's also the DNA which
when you hear people explaining
it is kind of sounds funny.
But it's really the crux.
Now, what does he mean
to make it happen?
So this is very strategic level.
We're going to talk a
little bit about it.
OK, great.
Now put it into my DNA,
how to put in my DNA.
But let's look at a few
things that are not here
explicitly mentioned on the list
that I believe are important.
So even though he doesn't
talk about this in this paper
specifically, he really doesn't
talk much about the life cycle
view of products and services.
Not that-- because it's
[INAUDIBLE] CSR in general.
So I think that's been much
more developed since this
was published.
But this idea that
you really need
to think of the life cycle
of a product or a service
to try to inform this process
I guess is a specific, I guess,
tool or at least view
of the world that
helps inform this process.
Because how do you
inform which areas
you can prioritize or not is
not very well determined here.
That's one thing.
And as a consequence of
that, if you remember
from life cycle and all
the things we've heard,
is that most of the emissions
of any single company,
actually-- it doesn't matter
which company you look at--
are not within your
company, right?
They're always in your suppliers
or your customers, which
creates a more importance to
make those external connections
as part of your strategy.
I think he does mention
it here in some places.
But I think he was not as
clear because of the scope
of this particular paper.
It was too CSR generic.
When talking about
environmental, even social
aspects, most of the impacts
are outside your company
just because of the way the
companies are structure.
When you have a
life cycle view, you
have to put more emphasis in
those external connections,
more than maybe he
tries to portray
in this particular
article, which
is why we talk
about supply chain,
let's say, as an enabler
of this strategy.
But the priorities
of the high level
need to be connected
to the same principles.
But this lack of emphasis on the
life cycle view on your supply
chain I think is the
one thing that I believe
is a little bit lacking.
But let's look at page
five and take a look
at that diagram of page five.
I think that diagram of page
five looks awfully familiar
or at least should look awfully
familiar except that ours
is prettier.
Actually, his is prettier.
So you have all the functions of
the firm, the same thing we had
on our day one on the class.
And he has, like this inbound
logistics on the left side
as the function to
bring things in.
And he has as well
some ideas that you
have [INAUDIBLE] looking
inside out aspect of it--
transportation, emissions,
et cetera, et cetera.
Then you have operations.
You have emissions and waste.
These are kind of
the things that you
think you should look for inside
your company for inspiration
of where to take action.
You have [INAUDIBLE] logistics.
He has packaging
use and disposal.
Then you have
marketing and sales.
This more advertising.
And information is more
about communication.
And you have the
after sale services
and you have your disposal
of obsolete products,
handling of consumables, some
of the dimensions to look at.
Then you have the
procurement function
that, in the view of a
company and the strategy
specifically the
way Porter likes
to think about value
chains, he sees procurement
as a about supporting function
for all these functions.
And he lists on
the right side-- he
talks about use of
particular inputs
and have this bullet
of utilization
of natural resources.
So all these kind of
bullets here in this diagram
are the area you should
look for-- things
to include in your
strategy, I guess,
and prioritize one
over the other.
So you could choose and work
more on reducing of packaging.
That's what you could do.
All these are levers
that you can somehow
engage that are aligned with
what you do as a company.
And if you go through
this list, you
will see very quickly that
there's some things that you
see all over the place happening
that make sense to companies.
So let's start with one-- waste.
waste-- why is waste always to
work in every single company?
Waste is money that you are
throwing to the garbage.
So whenever you
can go to extract
value of that waste--
always going to work.
So this is kind of
a natural connection
with any environmental
initiative
you find in the planet.
Doesn't matter which one it is.
Even if your company
does like zero interest
in the environment, waste always
connects with the environment--
always.
So that's always a
natural-- you see
that highlighted in your
reports of your companies--
you know, zero waste plants,
zero waste to landfill.
Waste is always
one of those areas.
And that's just because
that connects to operations
very directly.
That also is usually not
measured the first time around.
The company has not measured it.
And you start
measuring and people
can relate to dimensions
because they work with materials
every single day.
And you can put targets
that are very aggressive.
And you can also put a vision
that everyone understands--
that is, zero waste.
So if you see of any company
that is doing tangentially
trying to get this
started, you see
some sort of waste initiative.
Again, why?
Because any plant manager, any
distribution center manager,
anyone that manages anything
that is physical waste,
you can also relate it to.
That's always a good way
for companies to start.
The problem is
it's not connected
to the whole
strategy, but that's
always another thing
you find that I think
is very easy to
measure, which gives me
to the other one that is next
to it on outbound packaging.
Packaging is another
way of waste.
It's waste that happens
once you ship your products.
It's visible to your customers.
That's an easy way to start.
Transportation impacts
also on the bottom line.
I'm looking at those.
Those our people see
less miles traveled.
That's less cost.
Less fuel consumption--
that's less fuel.
That's also less cost.
Bury, resell your
[INAUDIBLE] that's
less distance, which is
less cost and also emission.
So you see that
those ones over there
are the ones that connect
easily with your business
but not necessarily connect
easily with your strategy.
That's why companies have that
always because people grasp it.
But that doesn't mean according
to the whole framework,
those are the issues
to put emphasis on.
The fact that you can do them
doesn't mean you have to.
Go ahead.
STUDENT: Here.
I have a question.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
STUDENT: It's how to
determine the boundaries
of your responsibility
as a company.
Because especially when
you manage a supply chain,
there are a lot of
levels of vendors.
There are a lot of
suppliers that at the end,
you don't know
who's supplying you
and you don't know if they
are compliant with those,
whether it's [INAUDIBLE]
for the company.
So how to determine
those boundaries
of the responsibility
of the company.
PROFESSOR: So let's
talk about that.
Someone has a thought.
How do you determine
your boundaries?
STUDENT: Well, we're
doing auto companies
and Ford is taking care of this.
So they draw the boundary
at their tier one suppliers.
And they say, we want all
of our tier one suppliers
to comply with the ISO
14001 standards for shipping
emissions.
And then they've sort of
thrown-- not really thrown
out the level two
and level three,
but they're doing studies with
the level three and saying,
we're seeing if we can figure
out what our level three
it suppliers are doing.
But it's not really the focus.
The focus is the tier one.
They provide training
to the tier one
on their environmental
management system.
So they're actively
involved in the tier one
and sort of peripherally
involved in anyone beyond that.
PROFESSOR: So let's
[? pick a little ?]
on Ford and the auto companies.
So based on what you have read
on Ford, what do you think
is their strategic
imperative for sustainability
and environment?
STUDENT: Well,
they hit it as far
as marketing for their vehicles.
And then besides
that-- so it seems
like they're getting heavily
driven by the Carbon Disclosure
Project.
Because pretty much everything
that is on their sustainability
website is almost
a copy and paste
from what they put into the
Carbon Disclosure Project.
So I think they've been
getting some external pressures
recently.
And as far as their
corporate strategy
goes with stuff that's not
being marketed to the customer,
they're sort of
convincing investors
that they're starting
to do the right thing
and being a good
corporate citizen
and starting to incorporate
environmental stuff
in their strategic CSR.
But it's hard to determine.
It's kind of hard
to figure them out
because they really
only give you
the politicians' line of, we're
doing this because it's good
and we're looking, like, all the
way down to conflict minerals
for our sources.
PROFESSOR: So from your
point of view, then,
should they spend
more time-- I'll
get back to you,
to the question.
But should they spend
more time looking at
their suppliers or not?
I mean, I know you're
not the Ford CEO, but--
STUDENT: I mean, for a company
that's as large as them,
I think it would be extremely
difficult and very cost
intensive for them because
they have tens of thousands
of suppliers.
And trying to track down
every single one, I think,
would be insane.
But they have a few level
ones and they are directly
involved with those.
And then the amount of
suppliers exponentially
grows when you leave tier one.
Like, as soon as
you get to tier two,
it goes up by order
of magnitude and then
another order of
magnitude after that.
And they think they have
10 tiers of suppliers.
So to track down everyone
down to level 10 I think
is impossible.
PROFESSOR: So I'll ask
[INAUDIBLE] of questions
if you remember [INAUDIBLE].
What was the life cycle impact
of a car in use versus--
do yo remember?
It was like 60% or 70%.
70% of the emissions of
the life cycle of a car
happens during use, which
means the number one
issue of your car company
should be fuel use.
Design better vehicles-- that
should be all your energy.
The rest is important.
Those 30% is important but
is not critical to achieving,
let's say, significant
impact over time.
So this is one way to
answer your question
and this is two ways.
One is where these
companies are trying
to put most of their effort
is in designing products
that are more efficient.
That's where they should.
I'm not saying they're doing.
That's what they should be.
Because you can
achieve both things.
You could achieve a better
sales, better market,
but also that's where
your impacts are.
I mean, if you really care
about the environment as Ford,
you should pretty much
say, you know what?
My number one
priority in the world
is to make the most
efficient cars.
We [? say you ?]
sometimes do [INAUDIBLE] I
think they have this--
you showed it last time.
They have all this zero
efficiency car or energy,
yep-- zero emissions car.
And that's where
they are aiming for.
And this immediately
answers how deep
you should work in
your supply chain.
Because if that's not
your number one place,
you should definitely
do the right thing.
What is the minimum
thing you should do?
You should mitigate risk
in your supply chain,
kind of comply on the things
that people are asking.
And that's why you probably will
see that they will go straight
to the minimum
number of questions
that the CDP report
asks them to do.
Because you want to
do the right thing.
I mean, sure-- you're
going to save money.
It's good for you as a company.
It resonates with your brand.
You cannot sell a brand that is
zero emissions if in your whole
factory you have
a bunch of waste.
And also this is related
to cost reductions maybe.
So all these things
kind of immediately
tells you my focus
is the product that's
where the impacts are.
Maybe what I should focus in
my supply chain are things that
have direct impact, put
my resources there--
some resources, and but try to
cover all the network of OEMs
that supply my car.
So this is kind of a--
I'm kind of backtracking
on the question, but
the answer is not
tied to how big you should go.
It's where your
impacts are or whatever
is the main purpose you do.
If your impacts are
in the use phase,
then maybe you should
not spend that much time.
I mean, do not ignore
your suppliers.
Make them better.
But it's not where you should
try to go all the way down
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] They
might have design principles
that they can help make
the car use less gas
or less-- be lighter
and drive farther.
But in the case of, like,
the Booth's shampoo,
Booth's is a pharmacy
chain in Europe
and they found out
when they looked
through life cycles [INAUDIBLE]
shampoo that the largest
impact is in the use.
And so they decided they
want to do consumer campaigns
about taking shorter
showers, using less heat,
and obviously changing consumer
behavior around your shower.
It's not a very easy to change.
So I think they thus since
dropped that kind of campaign,
realizing that they
can only affect
their own internal operations
and some of their suppliers
as opposed to the
downstream impacts.
PROFESSOR: So yeah.
So there was a couple comments
and then I'll keep talking.
STUDENT: --going to say
is a point of comparison.
I'm [INAUDIBLE] BMW and
most of the marketing
material on their own website
and others [INAUDIBLE] BMW,
it's all about the
cars [INAUDIBLE]
or the technology that
they're developing to make
their cars more efficient.
A lot of that's driven by just
German engineering but also
a lot of legislation that
is taking effect in Europe.
But another thing
that's interesting
is they have an electric
car sharing program
that they started up in
Europe and now in the US.
And so they're
really drilling it
on the use phase, which is
where they have the most impact.
So they're doing
a pretty good job.
PROFESSOR: And also
I think I do not want
to underestimate your insight.
That is, these supply chains
are massive, you know?
The car supply chain is
just incredibly complex.
They have no idea really
where these things are.
And they have really
very little resources
to try to spend time on
going after that information.
So they are hoping
that by putting
some pressure in tier one, this
will propagate down somehow.
And I think they-- the
list of priorities they're
doing I think is the right.
Tier one is probably
how far they should go.
Now, let's look at
another company.
Who else is--
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] so
I know in many industries
this is not even close,
but what if the place where
you can help where
there's more of an impact,
you're already very close to
being as efficient as possible?
So I mean, I'm assuming
that [INAUDIBLE]
this is not the case.
But in super efficient,
putting more resources
into that type of research would
yield much less results than,
for example, trying to work
with your supply chain.
So how do you even
determine where
you're reaching a limit
of what your levels are?
STUDENT: Well, my
take on it would
be most companies have an
area that they can address.
And so they might say
their most controlled
might be their logistics
system or their transportation
network.
And they can say they've
already optimized that.
There's nothing
else they can do.
But there's usually--
there's no company that
can't go to the
next level hotspot
that they can start addressing.
Some companies
we've talked to have
done what they call a
materiality assessment where
they look at things that
are material to the business
and then they assess the
impacts on each of those given
their products or their
operations or their employee
engagement.
And they pick all these spots
and they can kind of-- they
can kind of rank how they
address each of those, trying
to address the hotspots
of their products
or their own internal operations
and then maybe [INAUDIBLE]
down that materiality
assessment on how
they address those impacts.
I don't know if any-- has anyone
seen a a materiality assessment
as they come through?
Nothing out there?
OK, interesting.
PROFESSOR: So I want to hear
from another of the case
studies you're
working on in terms
of how did you go to
into your supply chain
or have you observed in the
companies you're working with.
Roberto?
STUDENT: I was
working because we're
doing Chevron and Exxon/Mobile.
PROFESSOR: So your
splicing is kind of short.
STUDENT: Yeah.
And it's pretty obscure.
So one area we can look at
is shipping, ocean shipping,
of crude oil from one
location to another.
Which, of course, there's
a lot of impact on that.
But aside from that, everything
else is just within the plan.
STUDENT: I'm doing Toyota
alongside of BMW [INAUDIBLE].
And they have the halo effect
of their previous five billion,
how many cars have they sold.
Yet they get hammered with--
the CDP scores are pretty low.
And I think that actually having
a car that is so successful,
an image, reputation that is
good in that market actually
keeps them from doing better.
And as a result, they
fall behind companies
that have cars that typically
are a lot more gas guzzling.
So I think you can have an
issue where a reputation
gain somewhere actually
prevents you from going further
in other areas.
PROFESSOR: I want to
hear from somebody else.
Which-- yep.
STUDENT: We're
Nestle and Hershey's.
I presented this a
little while ago,
but Nestle has a couple of
supplier tiers [INAUDIBLE]
to [INAUDIBLE] and today
require their tier one--
like, their direct suppliers--
to comply with their suppliers
code-- just in and of
itself a little vague.
But then the vast majority
of their suppliers,
like, for their
commodities, they really
have no control or
traceability over where
those products are coming from.
PROFESSOR: So let's talk
about-- that's a great example
and I'm glad you
brought up food.
And let's talk about
food in many ways.
So I just-- so I
just-- full disclosure.
So Starbucks is a
partner of our center,
which a partner means they
give us money for research.
But this is part
of the work we've
done before going to
research with them.
But I'll talk about Starbucks.
The same with Unilever,
same with Nestle.
And they have actually
the imperative
of trying to go as deep as
possible in their supply chain
as they can.
And let me explain
a little bit why.
So let's talk about
Starbucks, right?
So Starbucks coffee-- this is
supply chain that is very much
goes to fragmented on sourcing
side-- lots of small farmers.
Similar like Palm Oil, similar--
many of those are like this.
Bananas are not like this.
But there's a few
big manufacturers.
[INAUDIBLE] this one is
small parcel manufacturers.
And Starbucks, a little bit on
the way they see their business
is that we are
providing our customers
with like a third
home and third place.
They have some sort of
wording along those lines.
And coffee for us
is an experience,
an experience that we want
to transmit to our customers.
And that experience cannot be
complete unless we can tell
our customers that our product
is the best product ever,
right?
And the best product ever,
from their point of view,
has multiple dimensions.
It's, of course, quality,
right, the product, number one.
Safety-- you don't
want to get ill.
And you have a
place that is nice
where you can enjoy your coffee
and have friends and so forth.
But the other dimension they
are completely conscious about
is we need to make sure
that you are paying premium
for this experience and
we want to make sure
that we make our suppliers as
prosperous as possible for two
reasons.
One, because it's
the image we sell,
but the other one is that if
we do not make them prosperous,
we're not going to have the
best quality coffee ever.
Because if you take corners and
you don't wash your beans well
and you do not plan the
best coffee in the world
and you move to another
plantation and you-- then
you lose the best
coffee in the company.
I mean, it's somehow
embedded to you.
Unilever has a similar
view of the world
is-- we sell fish sticks.
[INAUDIBLE] it's no fish,
no fish sticks.
I sell fish sticks
for you to eat.
But if there's no fish,
there's no fish sticks.
So I have to care about how
people catch the fish-- maybe
not in the short term,
but in the long term.
So this immediately makes you
be much more aware on not only
the whole seller that you buy
your products from, but rather
try to go as deep as possible.
So in their cases, both
Starbucks, Unilever, Nestle
are trying to do the
best we can on some
of their key commodities to
try to go as deep as possible.
Now, Starbucks, because their
ethos was a little bit more
on the sustainability
aspect, on the shared value
aspect of your supply chains
from the very beginning,
they actually have much
better progress on that area.
So they instituted
the CAFE Practices.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
CAFE Practices
where they have actually a
supply chain certification
group that goes into the
farmers and actually certifies
that the farmers are trying to
use less pesticides if they're
organic and using less
water, making sure they're
paid above minimum wage.
And then Starbucks
Social has a lot
of different training programs.
Because one of their
greatest problems is farming
is becoming less of a desirable
occupation around the world.
That's not just a coffee
problem but a chocolate
problem and a tea problem.
And so kind of ensuring
that the farmers have
good quality of life so that
they continued to grow coffee
and they have a sustainable
source of the coffee
that they're sourcing.
So they have auditors
that go around the world
and they work with
farmers when they
have a gap that they're able
to improve their practices
in that area.
So they started up the
program, I forget, in 2008.
And they said they're going
to get to 95% 25 2015.
And so they're
about 93% of the way
that all these farmers are
certified around the world.
They're a third party auditor.
So it's not Starbucks going out
to these farms in Costa Rica
and certifying them.
So then you have
third party auditors
that they then report to
Starbucks who kind of has
the overall deal with them.
PROFESSOR: So they
have a database
with all their suppliers that
[? our ?] CAFE already did,
right?
This database is pubic.
Actually, in theory, you can
go into the CAFE Practices
website.
STUDENT: You can request it.
PROFESSOR: You can request it.
It's not public published but
it's public of view requested.
They may say no, but
you can ask again.
And maybe eventually, they
give you some information.
So they have gone deep, deep,
deep in your supply chain--
as deep as they can do with
the resources they have.
And the resources
Alexi was outlining
is we set up the practices.
We ask our buyers of
coffee that unless you
are willing to pay
a little bit more
for coffee that is CAFE
certified so you have
the incentive and you're going
to eventually make this happen.
We do not force our
suppliers to sell to us.
They can sell to other people.
So the CAFE practices are not
only for Starbucks suppliers.
Same with Unilever
and the Palm Oil.
I guess you went through
all the Palm Oil discussions
so I will not repeat it.
But Unilever is now trying
to go directly to Palm Oil.
Straight-- no commodity pricing.
Let's avoid that, let's say,
that lack of transparency.
Because it's so important
to us that we'd rather
pay a little bit
more because this
is what We need to care about.
So it's a little
bit of how deep.
In this case, it
went really deep.
Because this is--
food supply chains,
especially agricultural ones,
are very critical for them
as a business.
So this would be a
sense of how deep you
go is a function of
where you are impacts are
and where your interests
are and your risks are
as well as a company.
Anything else on that question?
That's a very important one.
Any other of your companies
that you-- is either different?
No?
All right, good.
So let me then get you
back to a couple of slides
that we set up at the beginning.
And I will try to
give you-- this
was the first slide that
when we started the course,
we kind of went through it.
So [INAUDIBLE] All
right, so these
were the way we
structured the course.
Let me kind of try to explain
why we did that work now
that you have a better sense
of what the strategy is.
The strategy is actually to
say no to many of the things
that we have here.
That's what a company should do.
One is to understand that just
because of the nature of how
businesses have
been developed, you
have to somehow
take this life cycle
view of your
product, which means
you have to not only
think about the things
you control and
buy from, and you
have to somehow make sure
you keep in your radar
how you use and
recover your products.
Let me give you an
interesting example
today which goes back to how
companies do their businesses.
Do know what the
espresso-- the company that
does these automated things?
So we have a friend of
mine from the Netherlands--
and also I have an
espresso machine.
He has an espresso
machine as well.
Pretty crazy-- we're
talking about this.
Oh, [INAUDIBLE] great.
So are you part of
their recycling program?
Espresso has a
recycling program?
Yeah, they have one.
It's very important to Europe.
When you get all your
packages, you get like a bag.
And you put your used bags
and they recycle it for you.
Because these
instant-- the packages
of coffee that you
process your machine
are designed to be high quality.
But they cannot be processed
in the US for recycling.
So they're waste and
they're lots of waste
and in Europe either.
So basically, they
have the whole program
for espresso customers is
highly advertised in Europe
on the closed loop.
And here in the US,
is there somewhere
in the website that
is not the core thing?
And now they have-- just to
tell you that even this view,
you have to have a
market that cares, right?
So even if you think of
the best process in the US,
people maybe don't
care about recycling.
So it's too expensive.
We know how hard it is
to set up those systems.
So in Europe, that's
much more developed.
Anyway, so the first
business to understand
that you have to decide in
this system is not easy.
And we know that's not easy.
And you're required to either
partner with a third party
and you have the
scale like we're
talking in [INAUDIBLE] and the
connection with the customer.
You may be able to do this by
yourself, but most of the time,
you'll probably
have to do, leverage
a separate supply chain may
be expensive at the beginning.
But over time, it
will get better.
But if you need
to own this, this
is going to be a
little bit hard.
So that's understanding a little
bit of the challenges of these
because this is very
less studied in general
in most companies--
was one of our goals.
Started using the life
cycle view of the world.
Then we really went
into understanding
how to make the measurements
of, at least in some degree, how
a measurement is done
on the use of resources,
the life cycle assessment.
Why?
Because measurement
is the only way
you can eventually make
decisions at some point.
Doesn't matter how
committed you are.
At some point, you have
to make a trade off.
Should I do this or do that?
I love the talk from
Seventh Generation.
I thought it was great.
Should you should
use these bags that
are worse off for
the environment,
or should we use our laundry
detergent containers?
That's a really
concrete decision
you do every single day.
If you have no measurement, you
cannot make the decision well.
They know that
what they're doing
is worse for the environment
on an individual unit basis.
But they also know that
if they don't offer that,
they will not be in the shelf.
So as a whole, it's better
to be bad on one product
but better as a business.
And that decision
can only be made
if you have the information.
Otherwise, you will
never be able to make
the decisions bad or
good or conscious or not.
That's why life cycle
assessment, understanding life
cycle analysis,
and try to bring it
as close as possible to product
design is very important.
That's what we
including in this class.
Even though it's a
supply chain class
and this is a whole course
on life cycle assessment,
you need to understand that to
be able to make real product
decisions and real
supply chain decisions,
you have to somehow get into
grabbing this information.
This is what Nike did very well.
After the whole process
and labor and they
embraced sustainability,
they created
a Nike considered index
for their products
and they did life cycle
analysis of materials.
And they tried to
inform their decisions
as best as possible--
measurements
so people can make the decisions
of the moment of making
that trade off.
That was the idea of getting
carbon life cycles thinking
into the course.
And the other [? rest ?] of the
course was a little bit more
focused on the other
stakeholders that
push you one way or the other
to make the moral case, make
the reputational case through
a tax or partnership, right?
These are the stakeholders
that actually push you
a lot towards this thinking.
This is stakeholders.
You need to understand them.
You need to somehow understand
them and engage them
but engage them not to agree
with them on those cases,
but to try to use them
to inform eventually
how to make those products.
This is why you need
to really understand
where policy is going.
We saw the policy talk.
Policy unfortunately
is going nowhere.
This is not going to
be a policy discussion.
We know that policy
is very convoluted.
It's going to be lagging always.
So as a company, if you
really want to be strategic,
you need to be more about
either understanding
where the interests
are of your customers,
where you can find
competitive advantage,
where you can tie that to cost
savings, something like that.
But if you post, it's going
to move very, very slowly.
You can drive policy a
little bit further ahead,
but you saw the
process of Mercury.
And that's the easy one.
The CO2 greenhouse gas policy
discussion is stalled forever
and it will take
many, many years.
That's not a reason not
to do anything about it,
but you have to
be very much aware
that really effective
policymaking is not
in the foreseeable future unless
there's some big disaster.
If something terrible
happens and lots of people
die for something that can be
connected with climate change,
trust me.
Next day, you have regulation.
But right now, the
way things are moving,
you saw the mercury processes.
How many [INAUDIBLE] in total?
12?
14?
From the science consensus
to getting all the things--
and you saw that all this
is just really compromises.
It's never going to give you
to taking specific action.
So you have to be
very aware of that.
And you saw the view of
the NGOs which, of course,
they are really committed
usually to the moral argument.
That's their main driving force.
They believe this
is the right thing.
They are the
conscience of humanity
and they want to move companies
to do the moral thing.
And companies need
to push all the time.
I want to do the moral
thing, but that's not
where my strengths are.
The best way is to try to
do something in between.
OK, good, so we've
[INAUDIBLE] us
to how to make this
happen in a company.
So this is the talk I give
to executives when they ask
me, oh, so give me a process.
People like, like, five step
process or three checklist
or something.
But ultimately, it's
something like this, right?
It's what we were
talking earlier.
It's that you have to understand
the pressures of your business
which we have talked
to ad nauseam.
And you have to make
this decision that
is, say no to some
things and don't go them.
Somehow, do not do them.
And not do them means do the
minimum, do the right thing,
or do the things [? where ?]
to mitigate your risk
and pick a few that you
really want to do well.
And that's a kind of--
and to do that property,
you have to measure somehow.
And once you do
that measurement,
then you really set
goals and targets,
which these set goals and
targets is the one thing that I
unfortunately cannot teach you.
Because I don't
know how to do it.
I wish I could tell you
what's the best goal to do.
10% reduction of
waste per years?
Zero waste by 2020?
I mean, what is the best goal?
So Alexis, you have
a better advice
to our esteemed students?
STUDENT: Talking it through
companies, you know.
They assess where
they're at currently,
what quantities--
if you're going
to look at waste management,
they look at how they-- a lot
of companies will do a pilot
and see how they can do it
within the first year and look
at what the competitors are
proposing and other
people in the industry
and if they're the
first of the type.
The one thing that I've
read in a lot of reports
is that, you know, we're
putting high goals out here.
We may not hit them,
so better go high.
Then it's almost worse
if you put low goals
because then you'll get
critiqued for not shooting
high enough.
So you're never
really going to win,
but they go through
a large assessment
of what they think they can
do internally and looking
at competitors and kind
of gauging it that way.
STUDENT: What are thoughts about
levels of today or levels of--
PROFESSOR: Go ahead.
Yeah, have some thoughts, but
you have some thoughts as well?
STUDENT: I'm just wondering
if that's a good way to start.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so that's
a good way to start.
So let me just position this.
If you look at any company, they
have these vision goals, right?
Which just put
clear to the company
where are your
priorities, right?
We're going to have a zero
emissions car by 2050, right?
Maybe 2049, maybe 2030,
whatever the number is.
So you definitely need to have
this idea of that vision target
that tends to be
super aggressive.
Why?
Because that just tells
you where your priority is.
That's a way to say,
this matters to me.
This is why I want to do it.
And that's what you see
in all the CSR reports.
That's the number one.
The next one they do
is like Alexis said.
And this goes back
to the process
of setting goals and
targets in any organization.
Who here has experience
in a company doing
financial targets for sales?
Who has done it?
Who has been part of
a process for sales?
How is that done?
How does it happen when
you, like a company--
I'm the CEO of a
company and I need
to go next quarter or
next year for my guidance
for Wall Street.
And I need to set up
goals and targets.
How do I do that?
STUDENT: Well, we would just
have like an annual operating
plan process where basically
they would bring it
all the representatives
from all the sales divisions
and they would come
in and say here's
our major-- they could come in
one by one, like, all the adds,
and say, here are the
customers that fall under us.
Here's what we
think. [INAUDIBLE]
we forecast the business
that we're going
to do based on XYZ reasons.
So therefore,
[INAUDIBLE] number.
And they would roll
all that up into one.
And operation [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So they get
a meeting and everyone
comes with a number.
And that guys went back to his
team beforehand and said, guys,
I have a meeting
tomorrow with the CEO.
How much are we going to sell?
And the guy asked the other
guy how much I'm going to sell.
Eventually, someone that
really knows what happens
says, oh yeah,
have 20 customers.
I predict my 20% growth.
I see these opportunities.
And they roll it
up and then they
could make some guesses, right?
And they just-- I rounded up
the number [INAUDIBLE] good.
The CEO says it doesn't
look good enough.
You have to do better
than this, right?
And the CEO says 10% more.
You say, I don't know.
Yes, you do it and
then you do it.
And next year,
they do it, right?
And that's-- and that's
the way it happens.
And I'm kind of a little
bit excited [INAUDIBLE].
But this is roughly
what happens.
I mean, you can make all the
nice frameworks you want.
You [INAUDIBLE] to the target.
But this explains what happens.
Someone cares about this number.
They force you to think about
what's the best way to do it.
And you go back to
your team and try
to find some sort of middle
ground between what you think
is doable, what you
really think you can do,
and your manager and the
CEO tries to stretch you
beyond that limit.
So you do not just set a
number that makes no sense.
Because everyone's going
to put a number that I know
I'm going to meet.
And the CEO knows this.
And because of that, he
says, I want double of that.
And you play the
game of tension.
And you miss one year.
You don't get the bonus and
make sure you do a better job.
That process is exactly
the same process
you should go for
environment targets, right?
It's exactly the same process.
I mentioned at the end of this
long rant one important thing.
Your bonus is set
to this, right?
So that means money.
But some sort of incentive
is set to this process.
If there's no incentive or
penalty, nothing gets done.
So you can get, in the
short term, some things.
But in other things, you need
to provide specific targets.
So this is where,
again, we go back
to-- you want to do carbon
footprint emissions?
You have to tie it to something
that the person can do.
For example, if you want to
reduce 20% of your emissions
or go to the same level
of emissions as 2020
based on the 2001
baseline, then you
have to connect those
emissions to something
you can take action
on-- energy use.
Right.
STUDENT: Don't you run the
risk, though, of kind of,
I don't know, questioning
the integrity of the process?
Because then you could
have engineering in the way
you're reporting or measuring.
And if you tie some sort
of financial incentive
to the goals, then
there is the potential
to have a lot of effort to have
good results on paper but maybe
not necessarily to be driving
more [? real results. ?]
STUDENT: PROFESSOR: So
that's talk about-- that's
a really good point.
So the companies that
are successful at this,
they-- somehow the
measurement systems
need to be as reliable as
possible to avoid that problem.
Because if yo don't have a good
way to measure the progress,
then you can fudge the numbers.
So you have to connect
it back to whatever
metric of your
business you can get
actual reliable information on.
And I think that's why the
leading companies, I think
that's why they do
better is that, sure, we
want to do carbon footprint
and we do with [INAUDIBLE]
this big [INAUDIBLE]
protocol CDP report.
But somehow as
they go down, they
tie this to number of miles
driven on my car, number
of kilowatt hours of my-- so
that process of kind of somehow
connecting these goals
and measurement systems,
that I think is the hard part
that companies take a long time
to develop.
Because information
you need to measure
you may not be capturing.
So you have to build, let's
say, that knowledge internally
and then eventually try it.
But I agree.
If you do have some sort of
connection to the real business
operations, you cannot really
set credible targets and tie it
to money.
And I'll give you
another example.
I know you have a question
before we move to--
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] measurement
like in the Palm Oil case
and also with Chevron to do
third party verifications
of things just to verify
before they award incentives
or peform the
bonuses or whatever.
PROFESSOR: So not
all the-- so not
all the performance
gives bonuses,
but they do have an
impact on your evaluation.
So let's suppose you don't have
to try as a bonus something,
but you have to meet
certain criteria.
And if you don't
meet them, you know
there's a risk that
your job is not
going to be there for you
in two, three, four years.
No one expects so.
I mean, that was your question--
was that your question?
STUDENT: I'm just saying--
PROFESSOR: As a comment.
STUDENT: Yeah, one way to ensure
that the system isn't being
exploited is that companies--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, third party.
STUDENT: --use third part--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, absolutely.
So third party
verification is one way
to try to achieve
that balance and make
sure you have a third--
especially as you go deeper
in your supply chain.
But I do want to emphasize
that to be serious--
I"m not saying that these
companies are not serious,
but to be able to fully embed
it to your business capabilities
as a company, somehow you need
to set goals and targets that
are tied to ways that
are credible measures.
You cannot just be do your-
everyone does their estimation
of CO2, right?
It needs to be, I
have a CO2 calculator
that is somewhere in my system
that I can click a button
and know how things are going.
If I cannot do that, then this
is your CSR report that happens
at the end of the year.
Let me just differentiate
what I just said.
So everyone can
come after the fact
that I can do an estimation of
CO2, hire MIT, hire Stanford,
and I can go in and spend
six months, right, and do--
this how much CO2 you save.
Great, but that doesn't
mean that the company is
doing anything right.
If you're a manager, you have
to get a report every semester,
every quarter, and
this is how we're
doing so you can take action.
And the only way
you can do that is
to connect that measurement
of environmental performance
to something that you are
collecting in your day
to day operation, whatever
it is-- energy use, again,
number of tons of miles
you sold to waste disposal.
Something, right?
And someone has to figure
out how that number connects
with the environmental
goal you're
trying to achieve and set
that target to that metric.
This process is
what is difficult.
And that's why the measurement
is kind of the tricky part
because companies are
not used to measure.
And if you do not do
that, the only thing
you have is a great
CSR reporting machine.
You are not really
changing your business
or your suppliers' businesses.
You have a great CSR
reporting, which is needed.
It's a precondition.
Unless you know how
to do it yourself,
you cannot put it
in your metric.
You have to trust it.
You have to develop
the expertise.
You have to have
the right people.
You have the SAP systems to be
rolled out whatever you use it.
Someone needs to do it.
If you don't have
it, you cannot do it.
And this goes back to suppliers.
And we'll talk about
suppliers in a second.
But is there any questions or
comments about what I said?
I want to make
sure this is clear.
STUDENT: A lot of the incentive
is based on stock price.
Companies don't really
give out big checks.
They give out 20
shares or whatever.
And there's a conflict
between getting that share
price to increase and
doing the right thing.
For companies that
have target incentives
that are stock driven, do
you have any suggestions
for setting goals and targets?
PROFESSOR: That's
where-- the only thing
I like there is the Dow Jones
sustainable index even though I
hate that index.
It's a great index because
at least people connect it
to stock prices in
a more direct way.
Even though the connection
is because of sales MIT,
the majority is revenue-- like,
30% of [INAUDIBLE] is revenue.
But they have at
least some metrics
that are environmental
transparency that people try
to connect with stock prices.
I have to say that
public companies have
a really hard time to make
these aspirational goals
because they're not
connected to value directly.
This long term,
short term trade off
that prevents them of embedding
a good sustainability practice
is very hard.
Let me give you
the other answer.
Who was talking here?
Seventh Generation said
that, although they're not
publicly traded.
They said, our
shareholders know they're
getting lower return of
reinvestment than other.
And they buy our stock with
that understanding, that?
Unilever shareholders know that
Unilever is making some trade
offs for the long term and
they're buying their stock.
Now, the promise
and the belief is
that they're going to recover
that value over the long run.
But ultimately
speaking, I do not
think there's a good
connection you can make.
Allow me to be totally honest.
I have not seen it that you can
make a real concrete connection
between stock price
and sustainability
in the short term.
What I've heard
the argument, which
I think is a real
argument, is a company that
can develop this kind
of system is a company
that must have a really
sophisticated management, which
means this company must be
run by smart people, which
means this company must
be making some good money.
But this is a very
indirect argument.
It's not a direct argument.
Oh, you did this?
You can get money back.
It's more, if you're willing
to pull this off and not
crash your business, that means
that you are really well run
management company
and we believe
that you are going to be
able to achieve other things.
Because besides all
your complexity,
you have been able to embed
sustainability in your day
to day operations.
Is that-- it's kind
of a poor answer.
STUDENT: --Wall Street is
going to let you get away
with it for so long, right?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
for so long, yes.
At some point, that's kind of
an argument of capabilities
more than an argument of
delivering results is just,
you should be able
to do this well.
STUDENT: Just to quickly
build on this today,
we actually had the CEO
of-- I'm going to remember
the name of the company
in a little while.
They were investing
not in sustainability
in the green part
by [? Mosely ?]
and investing in their
employees and paying them
higher-- Costco.
PROFESSOR: Costco--
Costco is big.
STUDENT: --while still offering
low prices to customers.
And he was mentioning--
like, he was talking
about his experience of
having a really hard time
at the beginning
when they initially
went public because people in
Wall Street didn't understand.
But they kept true to their
strategy and that now,
their stock price has
gone up significantly.
And people who buy their
stock and trade it and it's
actually a very valuable stock.
But then it does take time.
If your entire
strategy is long term,
you kind of wait for Wall Street
to understand it [INAUDIBLE]
and into it.
But if you have a
strategy, it does work.
You wait for them, though.
PROFESSOR: I think that's
the-- yeah, I agree.
I think that's possible.
Yes, it's always possible.
Let me actually
say two more things
on setting goals and targets.
So I'm trying to
emphasize this point.
Supplier selection--
let's talk about when
you want to go to your
tier one suppliers
and make them greener, right?
And you want to really make
them part of your strategy.
If there's no measure in your
scorecards to your supplier
selection, this means nothing.
So when the buyer is
sitting in the table
and he has to make a decision
on which supplier to select
and there's no metric there that
says sustainability, trust me.
That person is going to
do their best effort.
Now, the problem is if
you have never done it,
how do you start?
How do you start
putting a metric there?
You have to give people--
educate them first.
You have to first-- I recommend
you to measure this, right?
It's not part of our
evaluation process.
You do that for
two or three years.
You first understand your
capability of your suppliers.
You have to get to know them.
You get their information.
That's why the CDP report
actually is quite good.
You have a structured processes.
They start knowing, you
know, we should mention your
[INAUDIBLE].
Oh really?
OK, let me start measuring.
And the next year
they come back.
I still do not
know how to do it.
The next year, they come back.
And eventually, they
get good at measuring.
You do the same for waste.
You do the same for the
things you care about.
You have to somehow
teach them what it takes
to measure what you care about.
Once they have that
in a few iterations,
then you can really start
putting it in a contract.
And I think if you see
what companies have done--
whom I was talking recently?
Yes, this may not be public yet.
So they have been asking
for their sustainability
metric from their
suppliers for five years.
And next year is
going to be mandatory.
It's going to be a requirement
for buying products.
It's a big CPG company-- huge.
And they have done all the
traditional greenhouse gas
metrics, waste metrics,
traditional ones.
And they have always
said information for you
to look into that information.
Starting next year, it's
going to be mandatory.
And if yo don't have it,
you're not our supplier.
And in five years, they're
going to reduce by 20%.
So I'm pointing out is that
there's a first phase where you
just ask for the information.
So people build their own metric
systems you cannot expect them
to be sustainable if
you have never measured.
So by asking your supplies
for the information,
even though it's not in
the scorecard of selection,
you start this cycle for them.
This is what matters to me.
When I'm buying
from you, I want you
to tell me how much
energy you use,
how much waste you generate.
Oh, it matters to you?
So I better start measuring it.
You somehow start creating
this cycle with your suppliers.
But only the moment where
you change this cycle into,
I bring it into your
procurement organization
as a decision making process
like price, quality, safety,
CO2 reduction.
Only at that time it really
becomes part of your business.
Otherwise, it's
just good wishing.
That is a long process.
So what I just said
is a five year cycle,
especially when you talk
about a large company
with many, many suppliers.
Great example of these--
Natura in Brazil.
They have specific targets for
the supplies of CO2 reduction.
They have their templates.
This is how you fill it
out, how much energy you do.
This is exactly what
you expect from them.
And this is exactly
how much reduction
I expect from you year to year.
And if you don't get it,
you're no longer my supplier.
But this took some time,
even though they're
a very sustainable
company as a whole.
And this is what
you do internally.
And of course, always
you have to stay
in tuned with your moral
compass, your partner that
tell you which are the
issues that you think,
which areas of the world you
have to be worried about that
could have more
regulation, right?
How can you make sure
your reputation--
you have to defend
all those dimensions.
So this is, I think, how you
can develop long term strategy.
So we have to wrap up now.
But on Wednesday, we're going
to hear someone from a company
hopefully tell them
how they did it.
So keep some of
these things in mind
to see if we can identify
these patterns going or not.
I think some of them are there.
Others are not.
So we'll see how good they
are in their strategy.
Ask tough questions and that
I wanted to do more guidance,
but I talk a lot.
For the team project-- so
what we want in your team
project is to not only both of
you dividing your companies,
but actually comparing
them, discussing
what makes them better,
and eventually trying
to make an assessment
is, is this company
that has a higher ranking
in CDP deserve this or not?
And this is why they deserve
it based on some of the things
we've talked so far, all right?
OK, thank you so much and
I will see you on Wednesday